- Bonjour, Christopher Nolan.
- Bonjour.
- C'est un vrai plaisir de vous recevoir aujourd'hui.
Vous êtes prêt pour cette interview ?
- Je suis prêt.
- OK, vous pouvez donc voir l'écran avec des emojis qui défilent.
Si vous appuyez sur le buzzer, ça s'arrêtera sur un emoji et on verra la première question.
Donc, c'est un sablier.
Un chrono va apparaître pour 60 secondes à l'écran.
Pendant ce temps, je vais vous donner une série de projections pour l'année 2050.
et l'idée c'est que vous me donniez un mot ou quelques mots, peu importe,
qui vous viendraient à l'esprit pour ce sujet.
- Ça marche.
- Allez, c'est parti.
Les transports en 2050 ?
- On volera, j'espère.
- La bombe nucléaire en 2050 ?
- Pareil.
- Les salles de cinéma en 2050 ?
- Plus grandes et majestueuses.
- Très bien.
Vos films en 2050 ?
- Euhhh…
Je passe.
- D'accord (rires).
L'exploration spatiale en 2050 ?
- Mars.
- Les villes en 2050 ?
- Plus hautes.
- L'amour en 2050 ?
- Pareil.
Maintenant, la paix en 2050 ?
- De l'espoir.
- Ok.
Et la guerre en 2050 ?
- De la peur.
Peut-être le dernier.
Les avions en 2050 ?
- Silencieux.
- Bien.
On passe à la question suivante.
Vous pouvez appuyer sur le buzzer.
- "Les trois quarts des 16-25 ans dans dix pays,
du Nord comme du Sud, jugent le futur 'effrayant'".
Le Monde.
- C'est un article paru dans Le Monde il y a environ deux ans.
Vous trouvez l'avenir terrifiant?
- Dans mes moments les plus sombres, je trouve l'avenir effrayant.
Je veux dire, j'ai grandi à une époque où l'apocalypse nucléaire était une vraie inquiétude.
Au début des années 80 au Royaume-Uni, c'était un sujet omniprésent dans la culture populaire.
Et vous savez, notre peur et notre perception varient avec le temps.
Et je pense qu'on vit une période où c'est de retour dans l'esprit des gens.
Mais le truc à propos d'Oppenheimer, son histoire,
et la raison pour laquelle je lui ai dédié ce film, c'est qu'il a changé le monde pour toujours.
On vit dans un monde qu'il a façonné.
Et ça, pour toujours.
Et je trouve ça effrayant, en effet, d'observer
le danger et la menace s'étendre à ce point dans le temps.
- Oppenheimer, bien sûr, on va en reparler,
a créé la bombe nucléaire pour les États-Unis.
Si Oppenheimer n'avait pas créé la bombe nucléaire,
le monde serait-il meilleur aujourd'hui ?
- Le monde se porterait certainement mieux sans la menace des armes nucléaires.
L'une des choses intéressantes à propos de l'histoire d'Oppenheimer,
sur les scientifiques de l'époque,
et la façon dont ils ont travaillé avec l'armée sur ce programme, c'est que pour eux,
l'énergie atomique était un simple fait de la nature.
C'était une découverte.
Et donc il n'y a aucun moyen de la supprimer.
Il n'y avait aucun moyen de garder le secret.
Ils voyaient ça comme une information, c'était juste la nature.
Et en ce sens, la puissance de l'atome,
qu'elle serve des fins pacifiques comme la création d'énergie,
et des usages positifs pour la théorie quantique et la physique atomique,
ou qu'elle serve comme arme de destruction massive,
pour eux, c'était dans tous les cas inévitable.
Mais je pense qu'un monde dans lequel ça n'existerait pas serait certainement meilleur.
Et Edward Teller, l'inventeur de la bombe à hydrogène,
qui est incarné par Benny Safdie dans le film,
considérait le soleil comme la bombe à hydrogène originelle.
Donc pour eux, comme je l'ai dit, c'était un fait de la nature.
- Et plusieurs de vos films soulèvent l'enjeu d'une menace pour l'humanité.
Je pense à Tenet, Interstellar, Oppenheimer, bien sûr.
Qu'est-ce que ça dit de nous,
car ces films sont très populaires, mais peut-être aussi de vous ?
- (rires) Eh bien, je pense qu'en tant que cinéaste, on cherche les histoires les plus dramatiques.
Et donc dans la culture pop et dans l'histoire du cinéma,
si vous revenez par exemple aux James Bond des années 60,
qui traitaient des tensions nucléaires et de la Guerre froide, vous voyez que
les cinéastes sont toujours en quête de la menace ultime pour notre survie,
qui représenterait la crainte absolue dont seul le héros pourrait nous sauver.
Quand j'ai découvert l'histoire d'Oppenheimer, ce qui m'a vraiment saisi
c'est qu'il y a eu ce moment clé où lui et ses collègues scientifiques
du projet Manhattan ne pouvaient pas éliminer la probabilité d'une réaction en chaîne
lors du premier test, qui aurait détruit notre planète.
Et pourtant, ils ont appuyé sur le bouton.
A mes yeux, c'est l'enjeu le plus élevé dont j'aie jamais entendu parler.
Pour un film c'est une situation très, très dramatique.
- On peut relancer les emojis.
Vous pouvez appuyer sur le buzzer quand vous voulez.
Et c'est du pop-corn.
Avec mon équipe, on s'est amusés à demander à une IA, ChatGPT,
(Nolan rit)
de trouver le titre et le synopsis d'un film
dans le style de Christopher Nolan.
- Ah hah !
- On va voir ce que ça veut dire.
- "Nexus. Dans une société futuriste contrôlée par l'intelligence artificielle."
- C'est bien prétentieux venant d'une intelligence artificielle.
- Oui (rires).
- "Un hacker rebelle découvre l'existence
d'un réseau secret qui relie tous les esprits humains : le 'Nexus'.
alors qu'il plonge dans ce monde virtuel complexe,
l'illusion et la réalité se confondent, mettant sa vie et le destin de l'humanité en péril.
Il doit trouver le noyau du Nexus
pour sauver l'humanité de l'emprise implacable de l'IA."
A mes yeux c'est de la foutaise, comme on dit.
Oui, ça n'a aucun sens.
(les deux rient)
- C'est comme s'il avait pris en vrac des éléments de plusieurs de vos films
puis essayé de les mélanger, et ça fait juste un résultat bizarre.
- Ouais, complètement.
- On a aussi essayé de générer une affiche qui soit correcte,
mais ça ressemble plus à une couverture de comics qu'à un vrai film.
Est-ce que ça vous inspire ? Pas certain.
- Pas vraiment inspiré, non.
Je veux dire, l'IA, c'est un enjeu dont mon syndicat, la Guilde des scénaristes,
se préoccupe en ce moment.
Je parle à beaucoup de chercheurs en IA en ce moment, et,
ils voient la période actuelle comme leur moment Oppenheimer.
Ils l'appellent comme ça,
parce qu'ils se tournent vers l'Histoire pour se dire :
"on est sur le point de déployer largement cette technologie surpuissante,
qu'en est-il des conséquences imprévues ?"
"Comment on gère ça ?"
Mais ce que je trouve encourageant sur l'utilisation de l'IA dans le domaine artistique, c'est que
je pense que ce sera un outil puissant, mais en fin de compte,
rien ne remplacera la créativité humaine.
Et tant ces modèles que la façon dont ils traitent l'information,
l'ensemble est fondé sur la créativité humaine préalable.
- Il y a donc de la créativité humaine ici.
Et ça fait un lien intéressant avec le film Oppenheimer :
vous n'avez pas utilisé d'effets spéciaux numériques.
- En effet.
- Y a-t-il un risque que l'utilisation de technologies très avancées telles que l'IA, par exemple,
enlève la substance de l'art?
- Je ne pense pas.
Peu importe l'outil, mon choix de ne pas utiliser d'effets numériques
pour représenter les essais nucléaires est surtout un choix de rendu.
C'est un choix artistique, car j'ai l'impression que les effets numériques,
aussi sophistiqués et réussis soient-ils,
et d'ailleurs c'est souvent très réussi,
ont tendance à paraître fades à mon sens.
Ils ressemblent parfois plus à du cinéma d'animation,
donc c'est dur de sentir une vraie menace en les voyant,
surtout dans un film où tout le reste est très réaliste, très texturé.
Euh... Peu importe l'outil, qu'il soit généré par l'IA,
qu'il soit numérique ou autre,
c'est surtout un nouvel outil au service de la création.
Donc, tant qu'on peut faire confiance aux personnes qui conçoivent ces outils,
euh... non, je pense que le cinéma continuera à se développer de façon passionnante.
- Intéressant.
Et dans le film Inception,
le cerveau humain reconstitue des mondes très réalistes dans les rêves,
au point qu'on ne peut plus faire de distinction,
bien sûr, entre la réalité et le rêve.
Vous pensez que l'IA pourrait bientôt atteindre
un tel niveau de créativité voire une capacité à dupliquer si bien
que ça brouillerait complètement les frontières du réel et de ce qui ne l'est pas ?
- Personnellement, je ne crois pas.
Ça ne veut pas dire que ce n'est pas un danger à considérer,
ni une idée intéressante à examiner.
Mais je pense que dans le domaine des effets spéciaux, par exemple,
quand j'ai commencé à utiliser des effets numériques, il était question de simulation.
Tout tournait autour de l'idée qu'avec les effets numériques et les nouvelles technologies,
vous pouviez parfaitement simuler un environnement.
Mais on a atteint une limite de rendu.
Et maintenant, l'approche est légèrement différente.
L'approche est plus photographique.
Il s'agit plus de textures réalistes, qu'on applique sur des formes,
euh... en valorisant la complexité du monde par notre capacité à le capturer avec des caméras.
Et donc, il y a des domaines où,
même s'il y a une possibilité théorique de progression infinie,
dans ces domaines, on atteint une limite parce que le monde réel est,
par définition, bien plus complexe.
Le monde réel n'a pas de limites.
Alors, toute simulation ou technologie numérique de synthèse,
finit par atteindre une limite infranchissable.
- Mmh, on passe à la question suivante.
Vous pouvez appuyer sur le buzzer.
- OK.
- On s'arrête sur un oiseau bleu.
Donc, c'est probablement un tweet.
- Ma vie est comme un film de Christopher Nolan. (des rires)
Je ne comprends pas vraiment ce qui se passe. (des rires)
- (rires) Qu'est-ce que vous lui diriez ?
(les deux rient)
- Je dirais, n'essaye pas de comprendre. Il faut juste ressentir.
- C'est intéressant parce que,
j'ai vu des films parfois complexes avec mes parents.
Et c'est tellement frustrant, parce que dix minutes après le début du film, je les entends dire :
« Attends, je comprends pas.
Comment tu veux que je regarde ça alors que j'y comprends rien ? »
Comment vous voyez ce sujet ? Comment trouver le bon équilibre
entre la simplicité et la complexité dans un film ?
- Je ne vois pas les films en termes d'équilibre entre simplicité et complexité.
Je pense que c'est surtout une question de mystère.
Et nos attentes face à un film,
depuis des décennies et surtout depuis les années 1950,
ont été façonnées par la télévision et les codes de la télévision.
Et c'est parfois dommage.
Donc, j'utilise souvent des structures non-linéaires, qui ne sont pas chronologiques.
C'était quelque chose de courant quand le cinéma était muet,
et dans les premiers films sonores, jusqu'à l'arrivée de la télévision.
Et puis la télévision a imposé en quelque sorte une approche plus linéaire, plus simple
à cause des habitudes de visionnage développées à partir des années 1950.
Puis, depuis que le DVD est arrivé et maintenant le streaming,
on peut à nouveau être plus aventureux
parce que quand on regarde quelque chose, on peut faire pause,
on peut revenir en arrière, revisionner un passage.
Et donc, on peut faire des récits plus denses,
des récits plus complexes.
Mais au bout du compte, le seul critère pour une bonne expérience dans une salle de cinéma,
c'est qu'il doit y avoir du mystère.
Euh, on n'a pas envie de comprendre toute l'histoire dès le début.
Sinon, il n'y a plus rien à dévoiler.
Et donc, vous savez, le vrai talent du cinéaste,
le boulot du cinéaste c'est d'essayer d'être un peu en avance sur le public,
pas trop en avance, pas trop en retard.
Quand tu es en retard sur le public,
et qu'il comprend l'intrigue avant qu'elle ne se dévoile,
alors le public trouve ça forcément très frustrant.
- Ouais, parce qu'on sentait que ça allait arriver.
- Exactement.
- Question suivante, je crois qu'il en reste encore deux.
Vous pouvez appuyer sur le buzzer.
OK, c'est un autre chrono.
En gros, je vais vous poser une série de questions
et le but est de répondre "oui", "non", ou simplement "je passe" si vous préférez.
Vous êtes prêt?
- Oui.
- C'est parti.
Vous ferez encore des films dans 10 ans ?
- Oui.
- Vous pourriez réaliser une série un jour ?
- Non.
- Vous pensez que la vie existe ailleurs dans l'univers ?
- Je passe.
- Après Batman, vous voulez réaliser un autre film de super-héros ?
- Non.
- L'IA détruira-t-elle l'humanité ?
- Vous refusez toujours d'avoir un smartphone ?
- Oui.
- Avez-vous peur de la mort?
- Pourriez-vous avoir un compte TikTok ?
- Non.
- En même temps, vous n'avez pas de smartphone, (donc)...
(les deux rient)
- Interstellar est-il votre film préféré parmi votre filmographie ?
- Je passe.
- Vous aimeriez réaliser un Star Wars ?
- La musique est-elle l'élément le plus important d'un film ?
- Non.
- C'est OK de manger devant un film ?
- Oui.
- Et de regarder des films sur un smartphone ou un ordinateur portable ?
- Vous jouez aux jeux vidéo ?
- Non.
- Peut-être une dernière.
Un film à gros budget a-t-il plus de chances d'être un bon film ?
- Non.
- Vous pouvez prendre plus de temps si vous voulez répondre à celle-ci.
- L'équation est étrangement simple.
Quand on fait un film,
on n'a jamais assez de temps et on n'a jamais assez d'argent,
quel que soit le budget.
Et donc je pense que la question du budget n'est pas pertinente.
Ce qui est bien plus intéressant,
c'est le lien entre le sujet et le budget.
Mon premier film s'appelait Following, et je l'ai tourné avec des amis.
Vous savez, on avait tous un travail à côté.
Donc on tournait un jour par semaine le week-end.
On n'a rien dépensé pour le film.
Mais j'ai écrit le scénario en sachant d'avance que ce serait le cas.
Donc l'absence de budget et le sujet étaient en phase.
Et je pense que tant que vous maintenez cet équilibre,
alors vos chances de faire un bon film sont absolument identiques,
quel que soit le niveau auquel vous travaillez.
- Donc j'imagine forcément qu'un film comme Oppenheimer,
c'était impossible pour vous de l'envisager
quand vous commenciez à réaliser, et maintenant si, bien sûr.
- Oui.
Il faut un certain nombre de ressources pour raconter une histoire d'une façon donnée.
En fait, je pense qu'on peut aborder n'importe quel sujet de manières différentes.
Certaines seraient à petite échelle, d'autres plus complexes.
Ce qu'on doit déterminer en tant que cinéaste, c'est
la possibilité de raconter l'histoire avec moins de moyens.
Dans le cas d'Inception, je me souviens,
c'est un film sur lequel j'ai travaillé de nombreuses années sans avoir moyen d'obtenir un budget suffisant.
Et donc j'ai essayé de réduire l'échelle du projet.
Mais ça n'aurait jamais fonctionné comme ça, pour moi.
J'ai donc attendu d'avoir le budget suffisant.
Donc tout repose sur l'histoire et l'ambition de l'approche que vous avez en tête.
Mais ce qu'il faut éviter, c'est de commencer à faire un film
avec un budget qui n'est pas adapté à son sujet.
- Il nous reste une dernière question.
Vous pouvez appuyer une dernière fois sur le buzzer.
Alors derrière cet emoji, il y a une vidéo.
C'est une interview d'Oppenheimer à la télévision française, le 4 mai 1962.
À cette époque, il avait déjà conçu, bien sûr, la bombe nucléaire pour les États-Unis.
Elle avait déjà explosé sur Hiroshima et Nagasaki,
tuant des centaines de milliers de personnes.
Et il appelait désormais à un contrôle contre la prolifération des armes nucléaires.
Alors le journaliste ici, Etienne Lalou, l'interroge sur le sort de l'humanité.
Je vous laisse voir sa réponse.
Dr. Oppenheimer, beaucoup de gens pensent qu'en
trouvant le moyen de désintégrer la matière,
l'Homme a découvert un secret qui le dépasse,
et qu'il est en train de creuser son propre tombeau.
Qu'en pensez-vous, vous ?
C'est bien possible.
Que..
Je ne suis pas optimiste.
Mais je maintiens...
un espoir.
- Qu'est-ce que vous voyez ici chez Oppenheimer ?
- Je vois un homme qui est toujours extrêmement prudent dans ses propos.
Après 1945, après les bombardements d'Hiroshima et de Nagasaki,
il faisait très, très attention à ne jamais s'excuser,
à ne jamais prendre une responsabilité personnelle pour ce qui s'est passé.
Euh... mais l'ensemble de ses actes,
et c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles j'étais intéressé de raconter son histoire,
ses actes sont ceux d'un homme avec un sens très, très développé de la responsabilité et de la honte.
Et donc la façon dont il a répondu à beaucoup de ces questions plus tard,
a toujours été très prudente.
Et je pense que c'est ici un exemple très éloquent.
Oui, c'est difficile, lorsqu'on creuse vraiment la question de la bombe atomique,
d'où ça vient, ce que c'est, et ce que ça peut devenir,
c'est très difficile de rester optimiste.
Euh... mais le fait qu'il veuille toujours garder espoir,
c'est révélateur de la personne qu'il était,
et aussi de son besoin de communiquer avec les gens.
Parce que si vous dites en permanence aux gens que le ciel va leur tomber sur la tête, ils arrêtent d'écouter.
- Dans le film, et dans la vraie vie,
parce que bien sûr, c'est tiré d'une histoire vraie,
les scientifiques envisagent la possibilité que la bombe détruise toute l'humanité.
Oppenheimer pense que le risque est "proche de zéro",
mais il continue, évidemment, son essai.
Est-ce du courage ?
Est-ce de la folie ?
Comment vous définiriez cette action ?
- Je pense qu'il est très difficile de concevoir la façon dont ces scientifiques percevaient le risque.
- Le contexte était, bien sûr, très…
- Le contexte est très important.
Ils ont estimé que c'est quelque chose qui devait absolument se produire.
Et leur évaluation du risque a été strictement,
uniquement, statistiquement subjective.
Ce sont des scientifiques, et ils voient le risque d'une manière très particulière.
Je pense que pour la plupart d'entre nous,
l'ampleur des conséquences l'emporte sur la petitesse du risque.
Mais je pense que pour les esprits plus scientifiques et logiques,
l'ampleur des conséquences n'est pas perçue
comme affectant la probabilité statistique du risque.
Je pense que nous tous, en tant que non-scientifiques,
si l'on savait qu'en appuyant sur ce bouton, on risquerait de détruire le monde entier,
aussi négligeable que soit le risque, on ne le ferait pas.
Mais je pense que pour des scientifiques, l'ampleur des conséquences n'est pas la question.
Le fait est qu'ils ont fait leurs calculs
et qu'ils ont déterminé que c'était très, très peu probable
qu'une pression sur ce bouton détruise le monde, alors ils poursuivent et ils appuient.
En notre nom à tous.
- Je suis content que celui-ci ne soit pas le vrai.
(les deux rient)
Oui et bien sûr, pour que tout le monde ait le contexte du film,
il y a, aussi, les nazis et un risque qu'ils aient la bombe atomique
et qu'ils puissent l'utiliser, et il y a cet enjeu politique…
- Ce qui est vraiment intéressant pour moi à propos de cette histoire,
je n'avais aucune envie de faire un film sur des scientifiques trop bêtes pour se rendre compte
que s'ils construisaient cette chose, des conséquences terribles surviendraient.
C'étaient des personnes brillantes, vraiment, qui étaient bien conscientes
du potentiel de ce qu'elles faisaient,
mais ils étaient dans une situation où ils savaient que les Allemands avaient fissionné l'atome,
ils savaient qu'ils tentaient de fabriquer une bombe nucléaire et de remporter la guerre de cette façon,
et donc ils ont estimé qu'ils n'avaient absolument pas le choix.
Et c'est ce qui rend cette histoire si fascinante.
- Et on parlait d'IA il y a quelques minutes,
il y aussi bien sûr cette question de repousser les limites.
Est-ce qu'on doit prioriser l'avancée de la science sur le reste et repousser ces limites,
malgré les risques qui peuvent être encourus ?
Comment on fait pour trouver le bon équilibre ?
- Je pense qu'on voit parfois des scientifiques perdus dans la pure théorie de la recherche,
et pas nécessairement conscient des implications.
Mais je pense aussi que c'est réducteur et simpliste de prétendre, eh bien,
planifier la façon dont on va gérer une avancée qui n'a pas encore eu lieu.
Vous pouvez l'observer dans mon industrie en ce moment.
Dans l'industrie du cinéma, les gens sont très préoccupés par l'IA et ses applications,
et ils veulent en être protégés.
Mais la réalité c'est que, jusqu'à ce que l'IA progresse,
il est difficile de savoir ce qui doit être contrôlé.
Et beaucoup de progrès scientifiques suivent ce schéma.
Jusqu'à ce qu'on perçoive le potentiel réel, jusqu'à ce qu'il soit palpable,
c'est très difficile pour le reste de la société de réglementer, de juger.
Et c'est là que survient le vrai danger.
Ce qu'Oppenheimer considérait comme le danger véritable, et à raison selon moi, c'était le secret.
Ils avaient dû développer le projet Manhattan dans le plus grand secret,
mais ils s'y sont opposés.
Les scientifiques l'ont combattu à chaque étape
parce qu'ils croyaient que les connaissances devaient être partagées.
Qu'elles devaient être ouvertes.
Et qu'ainsi, tant les dangers que les bénéfices
pourraient être partagés et gérés par tous.
Et ça s'applique à la plupart des cas de figure liés à votre question,
ce qu'il appelait la sincérité, vous savez, l'ouverture,
c'est indispensable en réalité.
- C'est aussi quelque chose qu'on voit dans le film.
Il est, euh... il souhaite la paix.
Et ça peut sembler, bien sûr, paradoxal avec l'histoire d'Oppenheimer qu'on connait,
mais il dit vouloir la paix,
et en même temps, bien sûr, il conçoit... ce qui peut être une menace et qui devient une menace, en pratique.
- Oui.
- Et donc c'est tout un dilemme éthique.
- Oui, il a été l'une des premières personnes à…
il n'a pas directement parlé de "destruction mutuelle assurée",
mais il était l'un des premiers, avec Niels Bohr,
à commencer à explorer et articuler l'idée qu'avec une arme si puissante,
le type de guerre qu'on avait connu avec la Seconde Guerre mondiale et la Première Guerre mondiale deviendrait infaisable et impensable.
Et il faut souligner, si l'on observe l'état du monde actuel,
que l'histoire lui a donné raison jusqu'à présent.
Donc…
Je ne sais pas. (rires)
Il n'y a pas... Il n'y a pas de réponses faciles aux questions que son histoire soulève.
- Je trouve que le film aborde parfaitement ces enjeux.
J'ai envie de lire sa biographie maintenant et de continuer à découvrir son histoire.
- Ah oui ?
- Merci beaucoup, Christopher Nolan…
- Merci.
- ...d'avoir pris le temps aujourd'hui et, amusez-vous bien à Paris.
Merci beaucoup.
- Merci.